AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME
CELEBRITY CHILDREN'S BOOKS.
ONLY 16 SHOPPING DAYS LEFT
UNTIL CHRISTMAS AND MANY
CELEBRITIES HAVE WRITTEN
CHILDREN'S BOOKS THAT MAKE A
GREAT GIFT FOR THE TODDLER
OR ILLITERATE ADULT IN YOUR
LIFE.
FOR EXAMPLE, UNCLE SI THE
CHRISTMAS ELF, BY ONE OF THE
DUCK DYNASTY FELLOWS.
>> BOO.
>> CHRIS: SO IF THIS GUY CAN
WRITE A BOOK WHILE ON THE
MOONSHINE AND HIS FAMILY
TRADITION OF HATE, THEN ANY
CELEBRITY CAN.
COMEDIANS, I WOULD LIKE YOU
TO NAME AS MANY CELEBRITY
CHILDREN'S BOOKS AS POSSIBLE.
60 SECONDS ON THE CLOCK AND GO.
PAUL F.
>> ONE FISH TWO FISH HATE
THE JEW FISH BY MEL GIBSON.
(APPLAUSE)
>> CHRIS: POINTS. POINTS.
BRANDON JOHNSON.
>> ARE YOU THERE, BITCH?
IT'S ME CHRIS BROWN.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
ALEX BORSTEIN.
>> GOOD NIGHT POON BY ELLEN
PAGE.
>> CHRIS: OH, JESUS CHRIST.
POINTS.
BRANDON JOHNSON.
>> STAY THE [BLEEP] AWAY
FROM ME CHRIS HARDWICK
BY TAYLOR SWIFT.
>> CHRIS: PAUL F.
>> YOU TEACH ME TO READ BY
VIN DIESEL.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
BRANDON.
>> BI-CURIOUS GEORGE BY
ANDY DICK.
>> CHRIS: OKAY, POINTS.
>> CHRIS: ALEX.
>> THE GIVING HEAD TREE BY KIM
KARDASHIAN.
>> CHRIS: OKAY, POINTS.